Speaker 1: So in related news to the the the
death of expertize, the disregard for science
and data and research, is that the fact that
the International Governmental Panel on Climate
Change released its long awaited report just
the other day.
And before we get to some of the key findings
that I find interesting and alarming, I want
to talk about an aspect of American culture
that exists within evangelical Christianity.
There's this pastor named Perry Stone, and
we're going to get to a clip of him.
But you're coming from this faith tradition.
I was raised an evangelical Christian, a conservative
Christian nationalist, if you will.
And when I was when I was coming up in the
church, it was it was taught that God gave
man dominion over the Earth and because of
that, we needed to be good stewards of God's
creation, the planet.
And it doesn't seem to be that way anymore.
Perry Stone here, who isn't some no name.
You may not know who he is, but he's got a
YouTube channel of like 650000 people.
He's the leader of a congregation.
People listen to him.
They look up to him.
They admire him.
The honor him with leadership.
And he is saying in this clip, I'm getting
ready to play.
Screw it, let it burn.
Yeah, climate change is real, but we don't
care because Jesus is coming back in Revelation
Chapter 20, when Christ comes back to Earth
and sets up his kingdom, he's going to change
everything and there's going to be a thousand
years of peace.
And so the sons of God and these are the children
of God, these are believers who return with
Christ to set up the kingdom for a thousand
years.
We're going to see a complete change in the
earth and that what we call the travail of
creation or the travail of the earth will
cease when the messiah returns.
So those who criticize believers now for not
being environmentally concerned or whatever,
we now have the book eons.
We know where this is going.
We know how in the end, when Messiah comes
back, look, what can I say something to you
and say left.
It's wonderful to do all that we can to help
the planet.
But at the same time, if you know what the
prophecy says, you know what's coming and
you know that real peace, real joy and everything
that men want will only happen with the return
of the Messiah.
And you can see that all through the Book
of Zacharia.
You can see it in the writings of Isaiah.
And that messiah, without a doubt, is one
man and it's Jesus Christ that is alarming.
That is an admission that, yeah, listen, a
lot of questions, we just don't care about
it because we're waiting for Jesus.
Our faith is.
Paramount to anything else.
We're gambling on the fact that Jesus is going
to be coming back to save us, so let it burn.
That is that is a remarkable admission that
I believe is held by millions of people.
And it is very difficult to pry that viewpoint
away from people when when it is not substantiated
by fact.
When it is only an emotional response to what
is happening in our world.
And let's talk a little bit about what's happening
in our world, specifically some of the key
findings of the IPCC report.
One is that.
Humans are to blame for for climate change,
without a doubt.
We are in a situation now where it cannot
be denied.
Reading from this article from Reuters, the
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate Change,
the IPCC used its strongest terms yet to assert
that humans are causing climate change with
the first line of its report summary reading,
quote, It is unequivocal that human influence
has warmed the atmosphere, ocean and land.
It is an equivocal.
The stark language marked a shift from previous
IPCC reports, which had said it was extremely
likely that industrial activity was to blame.
There is no uncertainty language in this sentence
because there is no uncertainty that global
warming is caused by human activity and the
burning of fossil fuels.
That was the the IPCC coauthor, Frederic Otto,
he's a climatologist at the University of
Oxford.
These are learned individuals.
They are well versed in climatology.
They're not making wild claims like a Mike
Lendell with zero expertize.
These people have dedicated their lives to
one single topic.
To get it right, to be an expert.
Not to be fueled by Dunning Kruger mania.
Another key takeaway is that the temperatures
are going to continue to rise.
Even the severest of cuts are unlikely to
prevent global warming of one point five degrees
Celsius over pre-industrial temperatures without
immediate steep emissions cuts, though, average
temperatures could cruise past two degrees
Celsius by the end of the century.
That is scary, and it may seem like a long
ways away, the end of the century, but if
you're getting ready to have a kid, they could
very well be alive then.
We're talking about protecting the climate
and the planet for posterity sake.
This is a literal, existential crisis that
we're facing.
What's the saying about it's an honorable
man who plants a tree, the shade of which
he'll never enjoy?
I'm sure I botched it, but it's something
like that.
And are we going to be the Perry stones of
the world or are we going to plant trees,
the shade of which we'll never enjoy?
Another key finding here is one that we all
are witnessing in real time, and that that
is that extreme weather events are getting
more and more common and more and more extreme.
They can tie this to what's called attribution
science, it's no longer guessing whether or
not climate change is the responsibility,
is the the triggering factor for the wildfires
here in California or in Australia or anywhere
else around the world.
It's no longer up in the air whether flooding
events are caused by the climate change they
know now attribution science.
That's something you should familiarize yourself
with.
In the past, people would say you can't say
anything about any individual event, said
IPCC coauthor Michael Wainer, a climate scientist
at the Lawrence Berkeley National Laboratory
in California.
But now we can actually make quantitative
statements about extreme weather events.
This is serious.
Now, listen, the report does say that we if
we were to to stop it, that some of these
changes are going to happen, whether we we
could go to zero carbon emission right now.
And some of these changes are still going
to take place.
But they're saying it's not too late.
This is an extreme problem, I believe it's
going to take extreme measures to get it under
control.
Whether that be the green New Deal, whether
that be some of the initiatives that Biden
has proposed, but it's going to take more
than just letting it burn because of Jesus,
Unidentified: that was about.